from NewsChannel 8 on your side chick
fill A's Dei leader Sparks calls for
boycott that's right Chick-fil-A has
hired a diversity equity and inclusion
officer uh VP named Eric mcreynold says
Chick-fil-A restaurants have a lot have
long been recognized as a place where
people know they will be treated well
modeling care for other starts in the
restaurant and we are committed to
ensuring mutual respect understanding
and dignity everywhere we do business
these tenants are good business practice
and crucial for filling our corporate
purpose blah blah blah they then go on
to list a whole bunch of garbage and
people and stuff like that at the bottom
they say that they have a commitment
to Dei look I'm from Georgia which is
where Chick-fil-A is is based out of and
literally was formed and founded
if there's any if there's a long-term
boycott of Chick-fil-A then
conservatives won everything because I
don't know that you're gonna pull that
one off because there's a lot of people
that are going to fight back on that I I
say I say boycott Chick-fil-A I'm not
saying whether you do not I'm saying if
it actually is successful I will be very
impressed because that's gonna be a very
I could not imagine a more difficult
company to talk conservative moms into
boycotting in my whole state of Georgia
even if even if you're showing them this
they will Overlook a lot and I think a
lot of those moms don't when you just
say Dei like look they're taking their
kids to 14 different practices and
running around all over the place and
you're trying to say Dei This and like I
don't know I'm just getting my kids
nuggets with a pleasant person that's
nice to me well I get what you're saying
with the argument for it I just don't
know that it it will be successful yeah
so it's easier to villainize Bud Light
sorry no Chick-fil-A I would agree but
this is also part of why this is so
disappointing to me Chick-fil-A has sort
of had a a bit of wokeness creeping into
it over the years in 2020 during the BLM
riots I believe that uh the founder was
supporting me like don't quote me that I
might have either been the founder of
the CEO but there have been a number of
issues there and it's a shame because I
was very proud to support Chick-fil-A
and what they were doing for quite a
while and I thought the left's reaction
to them was very fascinating and very
telling because the left said that
Chick-fil-A was evil and why was
Chick-fil-A evil well because one of the
uh owning members or CEOs or higher-ups
didn't spend the company's money but
spent his own money donating to an
organization that was not pro lgbtq that
was that was in favor of uh preserving
there's a church yeah and and people
lost their minds over this now now think
about this for a moment Chick-fil-A is
known to not only be one of the most
profitable fast food chains per
franchise but they're also known to be
one of the best franchises in terms of
how they treat their employees they pay
them decently especially as far as fast
food restaurants go and they ensure to
give all of them one single day off
every single week where they're not
going to try to profit off of them
they're going to give them a day to
relax and be there for their family even
if it means they're not selling their
customers that day the worst thing the
left should have been able to say about
Chick-fil-A is well it's morally
complicated because they should have
appreciated the fact that they treated
their workers well but they don't
because they don't care about workers
they care about their sick perverse
sexual agenda and any anyone who opposes
it even with just a whisper has to be
absolutely destroyed and I remember the
Burger King released an advertisement uh
during pride month about two years ago
where they said they were releasing
their own chicken sandwich and their
chicken sandwich was in favor of lgbtq
Rights and you could get it on Sunday so
in the same breath they were mocking
Chick-fil-A for being anti-lgbtq and
mocking them for giving their workers
one day off of work Burger King should
be ashamed for the way they treat their
workers it's not just a sexual agenda it
is an all it is an all-around cultural
revolution yeah but I think it starts
with that I think that's a huge part of
it I I think it's just absolutely
obvious what this is like we talked
about this before but day Dei literally
is the Latin singular for God these
people are creating offices of God but
it's not it's a simulacrum someone
commented that just a moment ago that
Doma Linda simulator not the words of my
mind it is a false
image of religion that is being created
to substitute for people and they are
Marching In lockstep Like deranged
Psychopaths that's uh that's all I think
I think both are true
the son Dan Cathy Jr is not his father
and if I had to make a prediction and
bet
all the beer in the world on it I would
say that Dan Kathy Jr is going to Cave
to the left Dan Kathy Jr who's that the
son or maybe the second junior or
whatever of the owner of Chick-fil-A
yeah uh true at Kathy's the founder and
then I guess oh I see Dan Kathy is the
chairman is he currently right but is he
a junior
I disagree with you I think Chick-fil-A
will be one of the easier things to
boycott no I'm saying okay I okay I'll
bet you money on that one I'm just a
they're not a public company they're not
a public company which means it's easier
to pressure
no you can't kill you can't go after
their stock but but see the thing about
Chick-fil-A is that they already have
the disadvantage of being the Christian
company when it comes to the issue with
the left to the left is targeting them
very heavily and ignoring all these
other companies that have done anything
remotely similar I think one of the
funny things about the Chick-fil-A
boycotts on the left was that other
companies had made similar to Nations
but nobody cared it's because
Chick-fil-A was overtly Christian yeah
yeah Chick-fil-A my understanding what
they're trying to get into more urban
markets but because Chick-fil-A is so
pronounced conservatives have a have
identify with it and are now going to be
in my opinion much more offended by it
and you mentioned Suburban moms dad
might be like I go to Popeyes that's all
it takes all it takes is for the for the
husband of the dad to be like just go to
Popeyes honey it's it's across the
street the thing I get it but I'm from
Georgia and look I get the understanding
of like we should all this kind of stuff
but go to a Chick-fil-A in Suburbia
Georgia right now and you're not going
to see a lot of dads in there you're
going to see a lot of moms with a lot of
little kids and what I'm saying is when
Mom is like hey I'm gonna pick up the
kids after soccer and then we're gonna
go grab some Chick-fil-A and all it
takes is for him to say bring them to
Popeyes
if the mom doesn't care about the brand
at all
then the slightest nudge should knock
her off no but the moms love the brain
that's what I'm saying the moms
absolutely love the Chick-fil-A brand
but like I cannot think of a brand the
Suburban moms love more than Chick-fil-A
at least
y'all don't have them up here yet dude
not really what do you mean we have to
wear them all over the place we get
Chick-fil-A all the time yeah we order
big things of Chick-fil-A here we're not
going to do it anymore yeah I'm not
gonna buy from them to I would agree
with you if every Mall's got it I would
agree with you if the point was simply
that you know people are only going to
Chick-fil-A because of the more
conservative values the fact that
they've been maligned by the left but
they have probably the most efficient
drive-through system of any fast food
chain they get you in and they get you
out no matter how long that line
absolutely wrong oh no that is not wrong
you cannot absolutely
correct Snopes fact checked what you
said was true Snopes agrees with you I'm
correct about Chick-fil-A's
drive-through is overloaded well explain
if there's one drive through restaurant
one drive through restaurant that I've
left it's Chick-fil-A and that's up here
locations this was in Jersey and down
here okay in Jersey yes here's the
problem
and down even here so that's what I'm
talking about the south maybe y'all
don't have enough homeschool kids here
to run the Chick-fil-As like we do in
the South but that is like jokingly it
is largely run behind look man if you
think the moral fiber of The Homeschool
kids and conservative conservatives are
so weak they can't even push back on
this then so be it you're not going to
have me arguing the the strong moral
fiber of conservatives willing to stand
up I've been proud and impressed to see
that with Bud Light but we have a
history of conservatives of not standing
up for anything so that's uh you know
again I I get it but but also like about
the drive-through thing yeah crazy the
lines take so long and I understand it's
an issue of demand yeah but I I would
say every time I've gone to Taco Bell I
drive up I order I I when we live Mass
we we drive up we wait a little bit we
order we're gone Starbucks we wait a
little bit we drive up we order we're
gone Chick-fil-A we sit in line someone
comes out the window they take our order
we're sitting there a half an hour later
we get our food and I'm like there
there's there's two lanes to go through
there's an exit Lane it's it's insane
they they've prioritized their drive
through to such a ridiculous degree on
more than one occasion we've just been
like let's just leave and then we've
we've pulled out and left because it
took too long every time I've ever are
gone there I've been extremely impressed
with how quickly I got through the drive
through like I've been to McDonald's or
Taco Bell or Wendy's with a line that
was a quarter of the length of
Chick-fil-A lines I've been in it took
five times as long that's my experience
it looks like it would be different in
the South I promise you this that could
also because but the thing is when
you're in the South like I'm sorry I
also lived in Georgia for a number of
years service is usually much slower
there but when I go to Chick-fil-A on
there it is like you are in and out then
go to the one here yeah I may do that
tomorrow no I'm boycotting Chick-fil-A
Tim come on not yet I mean look
they're they they've hired a Dei this is
more than just a promotional campaign
this is outright saying from the top
down they have put a a a cult
non-theistic religious office in their
in their business yeah and it is it's
worse than the Chinese Communist Party
the Chinese Communist party as a
government agency puts Communist Party
offices in businesses in China but it is
an element of government this is a cult
that is putting its tendrils in
everything and the and the story the
media is running is that the right is
angry over like equality or something
like that they're lying of course
they're making up lies the reality is a
new excuse me non-theistic is a beer
non-theistic religion is now putting
itself in all of our businesses and then
forcing those businesses to destroy
themselves
unless like we're we're at the point now
where it may be the moral fiber of the
average American if you're right is so
pathetic that we're doomed
situation is that usually with this Dei
stuff when it's implemented my
understanding is it's because people
think that that will make their business
more attractive to venture capital or
shareholders but Chick-fil-A isn't even
a publicly traded company I I have no
idea
some kind of plans for Venture Capital
exactly
Etc but that's part of what we're you
know you're talking about the lack of
courage or sticking through that's part
of a large part of one we created
conservative ads Ultra right beer and it
was to encourage people to make a stand
and stick through that stand and and you
know Beer happens to be the Catalyst and
you know one thing I was talking with
Scott Pressler about is we're going to
use this as a catalyst too we're gonna
actually have on the cans like a QR code
where you can scan it to register to
vote because we have tons of rural
conservative individuals that drink a
lot of beer but don't vote and so we're
going to use this as a cat titles to get
those people to do that that is
brilliant tell them to vote responsibly
well I think if they're drinking
conservative ads Ultra right beer
there's a good chance they're gonna vote
okay
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time